what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Captain America's X-Men
team or the unity Squad uncanny Avengers
whatever you want to call it and coming
out of the last video right Captain
America and his team intercepted the
mutant Liberation Front which by all
standards of measurement is just kind of
like a Rec christened Brotherhood of
evil mutants if we want to call it that
but instead of Mystique or Magneto
leading the team it's captain kcoa now
one of the things that we established in
the last video we do not know who
captain kcoa is the original was Cyclops
but Cyclops is currently tied up in an
orchid facility with his eyeballs sewn
shut so it's obviously not him so we
have no clue who it is but again there's
all kinds of fan theories that are
circulating around out there some people
are saying they think that it is uh
stevil right Captain America from Secret
Empire other people think that it's like
Joseph the clone of Magneto so on and so
forth we don't really know but what we
do know is that by virtue of this suit
that this guy's wearing he was able to
break Captain America's arm right
literally snap his arm but the bigger
question they have here is why is
Captain kakoa at a nuclear facility Well
obviously it's to steal a nuclear weapon
and what do they want with it now one
thing to understand this terrifies
Captain America and the unity Squad even
if it's not obvious right it's like that
line from the movie Peacemaker I'm not
worried about the guy who wants 10
nuclear weapons I'm worried about the
guy who just wants one because who in
the world knows where he's going to put
it but is going to pick the place that
will do the most damage so it's a very
terrifying Prospect here now of course
Quicksilver and these guys do what they
can where they can and they kind of
manag to get the upper hand but not
really for their skill set it's really
more because once the mission's
accomplished and the nuclear warhead is
taken away right captain kcoa and those
guys are like let's go so they basically
teleport out and they essentially leave
now the other part of this is that
they've stolen an X-Men quinjet and the
X-Men quinjet is well known known to the
people of earth right they're well aware
of the fact that this belongs to them so
seeing some kind of like anti-mutant
force that may presumably have a nuclear
weapon although the general Public's not
aware of it yet it could present a
massive issue for the X-Men themselves
the other part of this is one guy is
Left Behind uh psylock tries to use her
telepathy to break into this guy's head
and then Mona St Croy does the same
thing trying to understand where they're
going to take this nuclear weapon but
they've got blockers in place right to
keep this from happening and so as a
result the team basically retreats to
Ellis Island and this is where stuff
gets cool because Deadpool just like
shuts down the X-Men here and he makes
them look like idiots it's one of the
funniest thing so what end up going on
is that Captain America manages to get
his hands on a kind of Technology right
that's not that dissimilar from Bucky
Barnes and in fact it is presumably one
of Bucky's other arms albeit just kind
of the shell that goes around the arm
itself as opposed to a full-on
replacement but it basically kind of
allows him to heal and then of course
he's able to throw the sh faster so on
and so forth but in the midst of all
this Rogue and the other X-Men that are
part of the unity Squad walk in and they
basically say like Captain America
should not be the leader of this team
anymore instead it Should Be Me Now
understand this is not like a straight
out coup right it's not really them
saying like we've lost faith in you
Captain America right it's not like a
vote of no confidence it's one of these
things where what she says is like this
will be a hard conversation to have and
we don't do it lightly but this is
taking too long cap we don't think you
should lead this team and where
everybody else is kind of shocked her
response is I'm taking over the unity
Squad we want you around but positioning
you as the tip of the spear is a mistake
the logic behind this is one part
reasonable but Deadpool calls them out
immediately right because psylock steps
up and says so many mutants are already
dead or missing if Captain kcoa kills an
Avenger the world will not hesitate to
fall in line behind orcus and if whoever
is behind that mask kills Captain
America we won't be fighting simply
orcus the Sentinels and the rest we'll
be fighting everybody that's actually a
fantastic observation because it's an
accurate statement right Captain America
is viewed by human society as just kind
of like this Incorruptible force that
was the whole basis behind secret Empire
right that like Captain America was like
the guy he's always been the guy sure
he's not like Ultra powerful he can't
alter reality or anything like that but
he's the one everybody rallies around
hence the reason why during secret
Empire it was so easy for him to take
out the superhero Community because he
was the last one that you would expect
and so with the X-Men approaching this
and saying look yes you're the leader of
the team but the fact that Ka kakoa
broke your arm like this and the fact
that he could have killed you and would
have right had like things not gone the
way that they had done it's a direct
indication that if you are the leader of
this team and this team has X-Men on it
and a mutant group out there that's the
Liberation Front right basically a
radical group trying to like overthrow
Humanity that's composed of mutants
kills you humanity is going to look at
this and they're not going to say
Captain America died on a team that was
composed of Avengers and X-Men so not
all X-men are bad right they're going to
take the Twitter approach they're going
to take the Reddit approach they're
going to say like a mutant killed
Captain America all mutants are bad
right extremist simplified views and so
in response to that Captain America is
just kind of like okay look right I get
what you guys are saying but like that's
not going to happen and then Deadpool
makes this off-handed remark right he
says people think I'm funny but you
mutants are the real crack-ups all you
do is lose right like what in the world
makes you think that you are in a
position to effectively lead a team and
come out on top and initially Rogue
thinks he's joking but he's like who's
joking here right I have not had time to
change my underwear since you guys last
lost a war there was the first mutant
Massacre then there's this new one that
was a frame job there were several
infernos and I don't even know what
decimation was but it sounds bad and how
do you react to cat being injured you
want to chase away the one guy that you
always bet on the one guy that never
loses even when everybody around him
does right it's not a smart play I'm
team cap and he says when the chips are
down you cannot start making fearful
decisions now this is classic Deadpool
right this is not like you know Jerry
Dugan uh Christopher priest Gail Simone
Deadpool right it's not like the comedic
Deadpool this is like like Rob lield
Deadpool except you know the feed are
being drawn adequately but this is like
Rob lield Deadpool right the serious
Deadpool really like Mark Wade Circle
Chase Deadpool the serious guy the one
guy who steps up and is like no so
here's how things are going to be but
he's also 100% right right like I mean
like when did the X-Men not lose right
like if you look up the definition of a
team that always loses it'll be like the
X-Men right like these guys can't win to
save their life and by and large it is
kind of the nature of the X-Men to
always lose and to always struggle to
always be on the ropes that's fair but
it's also an adequate observation all
you guys do is
lose this is a terrible idea but from
that point you basically switch over to
orcus that do a little bit of of
analysis here and one of the things we
find is that by virtue of orcus and
really just the news in general that
it's been broadcast to the world in a
variety of different ways newspapers and
so on that the mutant Liberation Front
right a radical team consisting of
mutants that are looking to take down
Humanity have stolen a nuclear warhead
so now public sentiment stands against
the mutant population more so than it
ever did before but even with Dr stasis
and modok that quote unquote woke up
this guy who became captain ccoa and
like brought him out of a stasis tube
and whatnot even they're a little
uncertain about what's going on here
right because the whole scheme with
Catherine kakoa is to create or really
to put together a radical mutant team
that will Target humanity and will
further orcus perception or orcus idea
that mutants stand against the human
population right it's literally just
kind of a back door job but even they're
uncertainty here like what in the world
is going on like why is this guy trying
to get a nuclear warhead so again it's
really interesting now of course at that
point you pick up with Captain kakoa
with what I told you guys was going to
happen and nobody wanted to believe me
you guys are like no Rob that's
ridiculous that's not going to happen no
it is like and it actually does right
you've got the Von trucker twins brother
and sister and he literally tells
everybody okay lights out in an hour
We're we need to get some rest it's
going to be a big day tomorrow and then
Captain kakoa walks into the bathroom
where the sister's taking a shower and
her brother's like hey man my sister's
in there and he's like yeah dude why do
you think I'm going in here man I'm
about to clap some cheeks and that's
exactly what he does right like the
brother's just sitting there on the bed
listening to it all go down which is
kind of creepy and a little weird but
yeah man the Von strucker sister she's
getting them cheeks clapped like you
wouldn't believe I told you guys it was
gonna happen right like some boots were
absolutely unequivocally gonna get
knocked like that's just the way that it
was that's just the way it is man I've
read comics for far too long to not see
that coming from a mile away but the
other part of this and this is one of
the genius moves by Captain America he
meets with Ben urick now Ben urick has
been around in Marvel Comics for a long
long time truth to tell Civil War was
the comic that really elevated his
profile just because of how popular
Civil War was and how many non-comic
readers had gotten into Marvel comics
with Civil War right it was just a
landmark story when it came out in the
mid 2000s but the thing about this is
that Ben yurri goes so far as to tell
Captain America I don't know everything
that's going on but I can try to be your
eyes and ears right you give me
information I'll give you information
one hand will shake the other and we'll
literally kind of operate in secret by
feeding each other Intel so it's a
really really cool moment there but the
big kicker about all this is for the
nuclear warhead itself we end up finding
out man this thing has been taken to
Empire State University these guys are
going to detonate a warhead at a science
fair sponsored by orcus now the question
has to be asked why because there are
much better targets to choose than like
a science fair at a university right
they could nuke like Washington DC right
they could go after like New York Los
Angeles San Francisco just like a place
that would instill the most possible
fear instead they decide to host it at a
science fair no clue why they're doing
this but I'm excited to find out with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end if you need to get
caught up on fall of x make sure you
click this link to the playlist and I
will catch you all later peace